we are at a huge inflection point for
the us dollar
right here and now it's one of those
does it go higher or lower moments a big
one
and the ramifications are considerable
for most things but especially
gold and silver now gold has quietly had
an extremely good spring coming off a
textbook w bottom in march at 1675
dollars per ounce it's marched over 200
higher through april and may reaching
1920 yesterday where it's inevitably
stumbled now why do i say inevitably
because
1920 was the price it reached in 2011
after 10 years of bull market one of the
most epic
bull markets in gold's history it's a
high that stood for nine
years until it was eventually the only
they're only briefly
overcome last year and it's such an
obvious
and long-term price point that gold was
bound to at least stutter there
as it did yesterday now gold looks good
it has to be said it's grinding upwards
all the moving averages
short intermediate and long term they're
sloping upwards
we have a nice trend silver 2
is looking very good and it's not often
you hear me saying that currently
28 an ounce if it can get above 30
then a run to 50 looks like it's on the
cards
even the ratio of gold to bitcoin is
looking good at least as far as the old
money advocates are concerned
turning up after forming what looks like
a long-term
low over the spring and that would all
be part of this rotation
we've been observing from digital into
physical from growth into value from new
economy
to old from tech to commodities
now i view as regular viewers will know
the incredible growth seen in technology
since the 1980s
as a function of the vast scalability of
digital tech one upload to spotify or
itunes
is effectively the same as getting a
million or a billion
vinyl records pressed in the 1970s and
money has poured into tech
because of the quick returns it offers
and for the most part as a result
tech has outperformed yet within that
broader trend
there have been windows when the
physical economy
has shone more brightly the 80s and 90s
were all about tech
but then between 2000 and 2003
physical outperformed the rest of the
naughty saw roughly equal performance
and then in 2009
tech began to outperform again and that
remained the case
for over 10 years now however
physical seems to be entering into one
of its rare periods of outperformance
probably at least in part
as a result of 10 years of under
investment
gold's recent outperformance especially
versus bitcoin would be a part of that
recent rotation
so with the recent rallies in
commodities tech
will win in the end its scalability is
just astonishing
but that doesn't mean physical can't
have a couple of years
in the investment sun but real
investment life is never as
straightforward as
vlogs about it might make it seem